I am Cheech Marine I'm Cali Hernandez
I'm Darcy Cardin I'm Steve Coulter hi
I'm Jennifer Coolidge I'm Josh demell
and I'm Jennifer Lopez and this is the
cast of shotgun wedding and we're on
BuzzFeed doing who's who
[Music]
maybe this guy
afraid of heights not every detail but
you know you guys look alike yeah he
looks a lot like you a baseball player
oh yeah maybe not not much okay no no no
no
you're directed Man and you're very nice
and indirect but she comes
[Music]
Cheech
oh yeah yeah
because you're nice I'm warm and oh and
interesting that's good to know yeah I'm
nice yeah
foreign
car seat just looks fine hey
[Music]
Google
keep going
love and not
I don't know
yeah me probably yeah just because just
because she knows how to do it she knows
how to operate the social media the
angles yeah the Angles and the camera
yeah
honestly we need to have like a a
tutorial tutorial please
thank you
these guys yeah
well they did every day every day three
months this
is at a party and a dinner every day and
Lenny
his own ghetto blaster he brought it to
the dentist
yeah it was great it was so cool I know
on other shows and movies I like don't
drink when I'm
whenever this one we were like five
course meal yeah we were just like
eating and drink and drinking and it was
um you know Raw
who's most likely to be like this person
yeah
don't mess with me I don't mess with JLo
I don't know I could be Pirate's ass no
no yeah
a stunt they always stunting me and Josh
got pretty
cool I don't know Darcy also but I don't
know if I nailed it on the first time
especially when we're handcuffed
together and we had to do all that crazy
stuff
except for the one time I almost went
over the cliff that was oh that wasn't
fun tell us what happened yes so you
know how in that scene where my dress is
on the wheel yeah one time it got caught
in the wheel oh my God and I was going
over and I'm looking at Josh I'm like
Josh
[Laughter]
hey every day you all went home and I
had to stay for my gun lessons that's
we'll have a gun diploma now
I mean it wasn't iconic
the entire time I was there they were so
afraid I was going to kill somebody
[Music]
over the course of relationships yes
but yeah
I take everything I can
and you should too I would probably just
take it just go don't worry about it
okay
[Music]
you feel like I'm flying by this
marriage I know
um Josh
me I can I it depends on what you mean
by prepared I know organizing like and
having like food storage and stuff yeah
like Doomsday stuff I do that a little
bit yeah maybe I can see you I can see
that yeah how sweet that you're
preparing for the end of everything I
know
it's a new fan you know how to come true
I got cases of spam with your name on it
make sure to watch shotgun wedding
January 27th on Prime video
[Music]
foreign